my guest this week is the Pulitzer
prize-winning American photographer
Lindsay adario Ukraine Afghanistan South
Sudan to name but a few she has been
there with her camera at the majority of
the conflicts in the 21st century I want
to hear about the stories behind those
images and what it's like living working
existing on the front lines of these
walls
[Music]
Lindsay thank you so much for joining me
and joining all of our viewers I know
it's rare for you to be sitting in a
seat safely away from what you're
covering normally with your camera
you've come to the world's attention
many times with your work over the years
but very recently at the beginning of
this year in fact just a few weeks after
the war started in Ukraine you did come
to the attention of many people because
you took a photo of a Ukrainian family
of four trying to cross a bridge who had
been killed and that photo ended up on
the front pages of the New York Times
can you tell me a bit about how you came
to that scene so I went and I went
directly to the East and was covering
the East for about 10 days before the
war started When The War Began I went to
Kiev and immediately was covering sort
of daily missile strikes and the
destruction and and those who had been
killed and injured and so
one day I was watching images come out
um from the wires and others who went to
the earpin bridge and there were you
know hundreds of civilians crossing the
elderly women children Crossing out of
European and all of those suburbs and so
um we made our way toward the bridge
through side roads and
um and as we approached there were
injured the territorial defense soldiers
were taking injured over to sort of a
brick wall off to the side so we ran
across the street and almost as soon as
we got behind that wall a round came in
so it was either a mortar round or a
tank shell we're not sure it came in and
hit sort of off to the distance and then
the Ukrainian military fired back and so
my security advisor said would you like
to go and I said no because everyone
knows this is a civilian evacuation
route and they're not those rounds are
probably going toward a Ukrainian base
that's often distance
but how wrong I was the next round came
in closer and so we Dove for cover and
as soon as we pop back up the next rant
round came in right next to us
essentially and it was sort of
equidistant between us and a mother and
her two children and a church volunteer
that was helping usher them to safety it
was very chaotic and obviously we were
all sort of in shock because the round
had landed very close to us everything
was very dusty
and our security advisor immediately
went to the aid of of
um the injured and to a soldier who is
nearby and by the time he called us over
um you know the protocols we wait to be
told you know it's clear you can come
and so by the time he called us over I
ran across the street not knowing what
to expect obviously I knew there was
someone injured but I anticipated it
being a soldier and
um although there were civilians and
Crossing steadily and even during the
strike I mean because nothing was
shielded so people had to continue to
move and so when I got there I Came Upon
these four lifeless bodies
um of course I didn't know if they were
dead or alive at that point
um I noticed sort of the tiny little
Moon boots of a child and as a mother
that was sort of a sort of incredibly
jarring and devastating moment and I was
trying to survey but I was also kind of
in shock and I one side of my brain was
sort of saying you have to start
photographing and you have to take these
pictures because I knew that I had just
witnessed a you know something that was
an intentional targeting of civilians
and so I took a few photographs but
rounds were still coming in so we were
our security advisor Steve was saying
you know hurry up work very quickly and
we have to leave and so I kind of have
moved around the scene and taking a few
photographs thinking in my head also I
have to be respectful and you know
perhaps I shouldn't show the faces so I
was trying to take pictures that showed
the faces and that didn't show the faces
so that we had some options but the
image I'm talking about certainly the
version I've seen
you don't necessarily look at the faces
actually the way now you've said that
the way that you look at the image you
can I you can't see them you can see
that it's more you look at the Sea of a
family exactly and so I've been doing
this for I've been covering War for over
20 years and I know that there are so
many images I've taken that have never
been published because they're they're
graphic and so I was thinking of that as
I was shooting as horrible as that
sounds because obviously I've just
witnessed the most devastating scene but
I'm also a photojournalist and that's my
job and so I was I was trying different
angles and frankly I I didn't think the
picture could ever be published because
it was civilians do you know do you know
the impact of that photo yeah I mean
it's been used uh by the by uh I think
the United States ambassador to the
United Nations to talk about the
intentional targeting of civilians
um it's been used repeatedly as proof
that civilians were targeted because I
was there I witnessed the run-up and I
and I know that whoever was firing those
rounds was bracketing onto that position
you mentioned being a mother has that
changed the job
yeah I mean it's definitely changed the
job in the sense that I'm more cautious
now than I was before I had children I
think to a sort of normal person who
doesn't do this for a living they
probably can't see that but for me
making decisions on a minute to minute
basis in a war zone I know I'm being
more cautious I know I'm not going sort
of all the way to the front or as far
forward as some of my colleagues might
be going you also are now seeing perhaps
when you see an image when you create an
image when you see the reality of a
child who who is dead in front of you
would have always affected you I imagine
or has it changed though yes it has
changed I think
um you know I photographed um I have
photographed children dying
um in Iraq and Afghanistan in Somalia
during the Horn of Africa drought in
2011 and it was always devastating but I
think now as a mother the first thing I
do is sort of put myself in the shoes of
that mother and I know you know I live
in constant fear that something will
happen to my children
so you're trying to keep yourself safe
but you're also trying to document at
the same time of course and perhaps
processing it in a slightly different
way I mean I you would you say you have
become desensitized though and do you
have to be in any way no not at all I
mean I think
um I think I have ways of dealing with
my emotion in that moment but um you
know part of that is just really
focusing on the task at hand which is
making photographs
um and looking through the viewfinder
that definitely helps me focus on taking
pictures
um but I'm not desensitized at all I
mean I cry pretty much all the time when
I'm photographing I get very very
emotional and that's okay I mean I you
know I don't have an issue with that I I
don't know what my colleagues think of
me but you know I I think it's normal I
mean I'm a human being and do you think
I mean you talked about hanging back
because of the risk as well not
necessarily going straight to the front
and yet when I asked you about that
particular image it sounded like it's
very Instinct instinctive when you know
you're not where you need to be and you
are heading towards danger correct and
that's obviously what I struggle with
because if I'm close and something
happens a little closer or a little
further from me but closer to the front
line uh I'll likely go but I think my
where I'm positioning myself is sort of
a little removed back and then making
judgment calls every day
um you know if I hear that a school has
been hit and 30 children have been
killed I will go you know if I hear that
a building has been hit on the front
line but no civilians were killed I'm
likely not to go so I'm weighing sort of
what will I gain from risking my life
although that building's been hit but no
civilians have been killed I mean this
talks to the idea of not you per se but
a criticism of those in your field of
being War junkies trying to find the
very worst to document and being in
places they don't need to be sometimes
causing perhaps more risk uh what do you
say to that you know for me the highest
Hall of war is civilian casualties so
that's not being a war junkie that is
documenting reality and the reality is
we're in a situation where one country
has invaded another and every civilian
who dies is uh is on account of that
Invasion and so I think that if I'm in a
position and civilians are being killed
I have to document that that is a very
important part of the job of someone who
covers conflict I'm presumably that for
you in in this work that you do you
don't obviously just cover the war you
covered humanitarian disasters climate
change the the effects on the planet on
that but it when it is about civilians
it sounds like the justification you
have to make to yourself to your family
and to those who could be critical is
that you are providing evidence yeah and
that evidence has been used already by
the United Nations have you taken
pictures of of people killing others of
the actual killers before yeah uh
I mean I've taken pictures of people who
have been accused of killing others but
I have not been there sort of in the
moment I I just wonder what that's like
as well you know the the seeing people
do the very worse they can do to each
other I think people are very smart
about journalists you know they
obviously don't allow us access to
things when they're killing civilians
you know I think that there was a time
in the corngal valley
um I was with the American troops the
173rd Airborne I had spent two months
living on the side of a mountain with
the 173rd
um me and a colleague Elizabeth Rubin
for the New York Times magazine and the
point was to understand the nuances of
War and why so many civilians were dying
in Afghanistan and in fact
um Lieutenant Colonel oslan who was the
commander of the Corn Gull Valley was
very smart because he had this
philosophy of transparency because he
believed that journalists needed to
understand sort of the nuance chances of
War to understand why civilians were
being killed and so we were in rock
operation rock avalanche which was in
the movie the documentary Restrepo that
I don't know if you've seen it but it's
extraordinary and
um so we were in that operation where we
jumped out of helicopters in the middle
of the night into the heart of Taliban
territory literally walked with
everything we owned for six days and
eventually we were ambushed by the
Taliban and we were ambushed from three
sides and there was a huge gun battle
three soldiers were shot one was killed
and in the retaliation of the American
troops I was standing with some of the
soldiers everyone was very shaken up of
course and one of the soldiers said look
they're using Afghan women and children
as human Shields and he literally had me
look through the scope of his gun and
there were women and children on the
roofs of the building where they were
shooting from and that is a case where
you it was incredible to witness and I
could only have witnessed that if I
because I had spent so much time with
these troops and really was willing to
risk my life and to be there in the
middle of operation rock avalanche and a
shot you took during that maneuver and
we're going to take a look at that can
you take me through it there is an image
the aftermath of that Ambush where it's
a very dusty picture it is a scout team
carrying the body of Sergeant rugel
and he's in a body bag and it was after
that and the the scout team uh clinard
who is sort of leading the way is crying
and they're walking through this very
sort of desolate landscape and I
remember shooting that photograph and
asking myself what are we doing here you
know what are we doing here years after
9 11 fighting in the middle of the
mountains where there are no people you
know and it just felt like such a waste
that this young man had died for nothing
and and in fact a few years later the
American troops pulled out entirely from
that area there's another image of yours
I wanted to bring to mind and for us to
have a look at and talk about an 18 year
old woman in labor stranded in 2009.
tell me about that and how that came
about so in 2009 I won a MacArthur
Fellowship that is in America it's
called the Genius Grant and it's
essentially
given to all different disciplines from
a cellist to a scientist to a
photographer where I was paid a salary
for five years with no strings attached
to just focus on my work and I felt a
lot of pressure to decide what to focus
on with my work because it was the first
time I could decide not be assigned a
story and so I started doing research
and I decided to focus on maternal
mortality and why over 500 000 women a
year were dying in childbirth at that
point this was 2009 as you said and
Afghanistan where I had been working for
a decade at that point had one of the
highest rates of maternal death in the
world
um and that was because there was such a
bad Road Network people women who were
pregnant or in labor didn't have access
necessarily to medical professionals or
to clinics or hospitals that were
staffed with doctors they just couldn't
get with anything they just couldn't get
to where they needed to they had to take
a donkey for 12 hours and imagine being
in Labor uh you know getting on the back
of a donkey and so I went uh to very
remote villages in barakshan province
which was one of these provinces with
high numbers and on the way back I was
riding with Dr Zeba who was also helping
me translate and we noticed these two
women on the side of a mountain and
there was not a man with them which in
Afghanistan is very rare and we stopped
the car and said uh what are you doing
here do you need help and it turned
turned out the woman on the right nor
niso was in labor and nor nisa's
husband's first wife had died in
childbirth and he was so determined to
not lose her that he managed to get a
car in the village but when we met them
their car had broken down so they were
stranded on the side of the road so I
said we'll just get in my car I'll take
you to the hospital we're going toward
faizabad which was the capital of the
state and they said no we need
permission from the husband so we'll
wait and so I turned I turned to Dr Zeba
and I said okay you have to find the
husband there's one Road in the whole
Province he's obviously on that road you
know so she found him of course pretty
quickly and brought him back and the
whole car the whole family piled in my
car and we took them to the hospital and
everyone asked me if she delivered
safely and if I took photographs and yes
she delivered safely but no I did not
take photographs because I felt like I
changed the course of that story with my
presence by taking them so you took a
photo I took about three frames and that
photograph is one of those frames and
that's when you had met and just seen it
because it's so striking the blue
exactly I met them we asked uh their
story and then we asked permission right
before Zeba left to find the husband uh
we asked permission for me to take a few
photographs do you think on balance
being a woman has been a help to you in
this huge help being a woman rather than
a hindrance yes everyone thinks it's a
hindrance but in fact it's a huge help
because people
um first of all have access to men and
women
and particularly when I'm working in
countries like Afghanistan and Somalia
where men and women are usually
segregated by gender
um and people underestimate women I find
and they still do and so they sort of
discount me and say okay sure sure go do
nice to be underestimated yeah I love
it yeah it's one of those things but I
mean I suppose on the other series much
more serious side of it is that again
when you're thinking and calculating
risks yeah you know rape is a weapon of
war is a unique tool wielded against
women yes and for me uh when I was I've
been kidnapped twice the first time was
in Iraq and that was only a day and and
it turned out compared to Libya was
quite sort of it was manageable in the
sense that we were working outside of
Fallujah I was working with a colleague
from the from the New York Times we had
heard a helicopter of American troops
went down we went to find it we got
caught by insurgents who thought maybe
we were with the American occupation we
finally convinced them we were
journalists they held us until Dusk and
then eventually let us go obviously it
was terrifying we had guns to our heads
for about 11 hours we didn't know if we
would survive Libya was uh much more
violent much more dramatic uh we were
four journalists in one car original we
had been two in each car but one of the
cars one of the driver's Brothers had
been shot at the front line so he quit
in the middle of the battle and we ended
up in one car
we had to decide how long to stay that
is not an easy discussion because with
four journalists everyone has a
different perspective on how long to
stay what our needs are how dangerous
the situation is by the time we decided
to pull back East toward Benghazi we ran
into one of Gaddafi's troops checkpoints
it was incredibly hostile the rebels we
had been covering started opening fire
on that checkpoint so we were literally
in a wall of bullets the men were pulled
out of the car me as the only woman I
was sort of left sitting there because
they didn't know what to do with me
but the car was not armored so I had to
get out of the car because I knew that I
needed to get behind cover
um I crawled across the back seat and
when I jumped out uh one of Gaddafi's
troops sort of came to me and was
pulling at my cameras uh instinctively I
was pulling back even though there were
bullets literally going you know next
all around us
um we finally made it to cover behind
the sort of uh checkpoint building and
we're all told to lie face down in the
dirt uh we each had a Kalashnikov put to
our heads and we were about to be
executed we were begging for our lives
um the commander came over at that point
and said you can't execute them they're
American which uh this was all in Arabic
and Anthony should later translated for
us
um if you know in retrospect I have no
idea why they spared us being American
because in the Middle East a lot of
people don't like our foreign policy
um and so we were tied up and
blindfolded
um and essentially for the next three
days we were beaten up tied up
blindfolded threatened with execution
and for me as the only woman I was
touched repeatedly
um I was not raped but of course in that
time being tied up and blindfolded I
thought of the many many women I have
interviewed over the years who have been
raped and so I sort of ironically look
to them for strength because I thought
well if they survived it and if it
happens to me I can survive it as well
are you living just minute to minute
minutes a minute yeah I mean in the
kidnapping there is no sort of an hour
down the line it is literally uh every
second is survival mode it is what can I
do to get through this fear what can I
do to get through this pain
um I mean it sounds like the scene from
a film and yet it's your life and I I
believe Jennifer Lawrence has been
interested in your life she was talking
of her film she was uh we spent about
three years together uh when Warner
Brothers optioned the rights to my
Memoir I wrote A Memoir after that
um called it's what I do a
photographer's life of Love and War and
um that Memoir was optioned almost
immediately by Warner Brothers Steven
Spielberg was slated to direct and
Jennifer Lawrence was slated to play me
um and that went on for three years uh
it was it like taking Jennifer Lawrence
to warzone
I took her to the border with South
Sudan when it was very very tense she
wanted to understand what it feels like
to feel that fear and to be you know to
be close to a war zone
um obviously uh we had to worry about
her safety so I couldn't take her an
extra headache you've got to worry about
Hollywood A-list that while you're
dealing with everything very stressful
let's just say when I put her on the
plane to you know from Uganda I couldn't
walk for a week my back went out
um but um yeah but she eventually
dropped out okay and so now it is being
made into a limited series so a TV
series a TV series correct okay but at
least Jennifer Lawrence now knows what
it's like to do your job she does she's
just come out with a movie playing a
character named Lindsay so yeah she got
that inspiration from but what if you
learned then from being in these
scenarios coming in and coming out of of
some of the worst things we can do to
each other yeah mean I guess I've
learned the capacity for survival
for resilience for forgiveness
the fact that human beings can be
equally evil as they can be
amazingly generous and
um and yeah resilient I think that I've
learned a lot from the people I've
covered but I think we have to look at
the ability of human beings to live both
within those situations and to survive
them after
well thank you very much for for taking
us behind the lens with you thank you
and thank you so much for being with us
until we meet again take care and
goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]